- So, do your kids
usually do anything cool
for Mother's Day with you?
Oh no (laughs).
(audience laughing)
- They call.
- They call, well hopefully.
(all laughs)
They call, that's a, aw.
- I get flowers.
- I'm gonna say, I'm-
- Well they're grown up, and they're-
- Well okay, but so what?
- And they're across the country.
- You're still they're mom.
- I know, I know.
- I do stuff for my mom.
I'm gonna have a talk with your kids.
(all laughing)
Wait, do you do anything with your mama?
- We do.
I mean, we take advantage if
we're all in the same place,
my sister and I, my mom
and sometimes we'll get
dressed up and go out
but then sometimes like,
we'll be like lets go to
In-N-Out and eat hamburgers
in the car, like something fun.
- And do paint by numbers.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I love it.
- Be cozy and watch like, you know some-
- Binge TV.
- Reality show.
- Watch Date Line
- Exactly.
- And those are usually the best ones,
- The best.
- And what she really
actually wants to do.
So we usually do something like that.
- I love that.
'Cause people always tell
me, like for birthday parties
they're like, oh, what do
you wanna do for birthday?
And I'm like, I don't wanna
do, I wanna just do nothing.
I think that sounds awesome.
That's a win sometimes.
- When you're busy a lot.
- Yeah, exactly.
Just take advantage of that.
My mom and I, we always, we
joke that we after dinner
we'll look at each
other and we'll be like,
have to go on like some
sort of dessert hunt.
So like we'll drive like 30 minutes
to a dairy queen
- Yes.
- Or something like random.
- I could totally fit in your family.
Like just by...
And reminder if they
don't turn it upside down
before they give it to you it's free.